[Música]
bienvenidas y bienvenidos
al gran teatro de la vida
al teatro de la vida y de la muerte
la muerte es algo incomprensible para el
ser humano
por eso fuimos de ella
no nos gusta hablar de la muerte no
solemos hablar de lo que no comprendemos
porque eso nos lleva al sufrimiento
yo desarrollé una ecuación
que vence a la muerte
interesante pero antes de explicarles
cuál es la fórmula les voy a decir cómo
llegué a ella
conocen al personaje histórico paula
escobar
bien
yo tuve una relación de destino
con pablo
les adelanto que
yo nunca fui narcotraficante
mi familia no trabajó para él
y yo no soy su hijo ilegítimo
esa genética que ven ahí
no está en este cuerpazo yo soy
muchísimo más guapo bien bromas aparte
lo que lo que les quiero comentar aquí
es qué
el día
8 de octubre de 1989
viajábamos en un autobús
unas 20 personas entre ellas mi madre mi
padre mi hermana de 9 años y yo que
tenía 12 porque el entonces mi mamá
había decidido que todos teníamos que ir
a misa los domingos porque mi hermana ya
había hecho la primera comunión
también ese domingo en particular el
patrón como le decían a paula escobar
había decidido enviar a dos personas a
que colocaran una bomba incendiaria en
ese autobús las bombas incendiarias
fueron ampliamente utilizadas en la
segunda guerra mundial
junto a las bombas explosivas
convencionales
yo fui
una de las víctimas de ese atentado y en
ese autobús mori
mi madre quedó con un 20% de visión en
un solo ojo se le quemaron las córneas
la cabeza la cara las manos
mi padre salió con quemaduras también
pero
el cuarto día después del accidente
jueves
se enteró
habían reconocido a mi hermana dentro de
las personas que nos salieron del
autobús y había muerto calcinadas ese
día
bueno realmente fue esa noche mi padre
decidió irse con mi hermana con un paro
respiratorio
de todas las personas que viajábamos en
ese autobús
a día de hoy solamente estamos vivos mi
mamá y yo todas las otras personas
terminaron muriendo por complicaciones
a raíz de ese atentado
yo fui el único que salió
ileso
sin ningún rasguño físicamente estaba
perfecto
ahora en sus mentes se estarán
preguntando pero se acaba de decir que
kristen es autobús
no me cuadra
desde los 9 hasta los 12 años
yo estudié en un colegio privado bogotá
donde muchos de los dirigentes del país
habían salido de ese colegio se habían
graduado y obviamente eso era un target
muy apetitoso para el señor pablo
todas y todos los meses
llegaba una amenaza de bomba el colegio
decidió llevarnos de excursión
una estación de bomberos
y ahí nos empezaron a explicar cómo
teníamos que salir de una situación de
incendio en un sitio cerrado me impactó
tanto esa visita qué
cada vez que en mi casa mis padres
fumaban yo me tiraba al suelo y empezaba
a arrastrarme del baño al salón del
salón a la cocina de la cocina al cuarto
porque lo que estaba haciendo era
verificando en primera persona de que
esa información era cierta y si era
cierta se respiraba mejor el aire el
oxígeno
lo que fue un juego de un niño realmente
se convirtió en un entrenamiento porque
dos semanas después eso que hacía de
juego me iba a salvar la vida
la sensación de salir de ese autobús
y empezar a buscar a mis padres
no los encontraba por ningún lado hasta
que de repente los veo en frente mío
es algo que detalló muy bien en uno de
los libros que yo escribí pero quiero
que se queden con algo interesante y es
cómo funciona la mente porque
qué pasó mi cabeza para que aparecieran
de un momento a otro
en mi mente no estaba registrado y
realmente no era en mi mente era en el
sistema límbico el cerebro en el
hipocampo es la zona que está
relacionada con los bancos de memoria
ahí no estaba esa imagen de ver a mis
padres cubiertos de humo negro y
quemados entonces lo que no había en mi
memoria no existía yo no podía reconocer
esas personas hasta que aparecieron
eso fue de mis primeras pequeñas muertes
de esas muertes le han seguido muchas
otras a lo largo de los últimos 30 años
por no decir más
lo interesante
de morir una y otra vez es que cada vez
que mueres renaces en una versión
mejorada de ti mismo
te voy a contar otra pequeña muerte
la primera navidad
experimente sin mi padre y sin mi
hermana
me hicieron darme cuenta que ese niño
ya no existía ese niño de 12 años había
muerto en ese autobús
pero habían ha sido otro
como nación nació con la creencia de
adulto y empecé
a asumir un montón de responsabilidades
que no me correspondían con la edad que
yo tenía cuando íbamos en una camioneta
yendo hacia la unidad de quemados recién
salidos de ese autobús empecé a hacerme
estas preguntas
tiene algún sentido de la vida que es lo
que está pasando expresión es realidad
es un sueño y si es un sueño cuando me
voy a despertar de esto
todas estas preguntas empezaron a crecer
a evolucionar con el tiempo hacerse cada
vez más precisas porque pase de lo
confuso a lo difuso y de lo difuso a lo
preciso
todas las preguntas que me hacía aquí y
a lo largo de mucho tiempo
me dieron la facilidad de desarrollar la
capacidad de hacerme preguntas todo el
tiempo de cuestionarme lo todo
desarrolle la facilidad de entrar en
autoobservación de mis discursos
mentales desarrollé la facilidad de ser
consciente de muchos de mis pensamientos
esto no ocurrió de la noche a la mañana
esto es un entrenamiento constante día a
día
esto no es así tú tienes que entrenarte
mentalmente tienes que entrenarte
emocionalmente para ser maestro de ti
mismo
estas son las preguntas que me hice
a este preguntas cuestionarlo todo
observa sus discursos mentales sé
consciente de tus pensamientos todo esto
se puede desarrollar
en la vida
yo creo firmemente
que tenemos que aprender a cuestionar el
ego tenemos que cuestionar a nuestra
personalidad
tenemos que desestabilizar los deseos
para que para que cada pregunta nos
lleve a una muerte y de esa muerte a un
renacimiento
gracias a este hombre
estoy aquí con ustedes y digo gracias
porque realmente le voy a estar
eternamente agradecido
porque gracias a este hombre yo he
aprendido desde la perdida
yo he aprendido
desde un evento traumático
un evento traumático tanto física tanto
mental y si me lo permiten hasta
espiritualmente
yo soy se podría decir que soy una de
las pruebas vivientes
d
qué es sabido perdonar
a una persona que te ha asesinado a la
mitad de tu familia
y lo he aprendido de corazón
sé cómo perdonar de corazón a alguien
que ha borrado la mitad de tu familia
desde el agradecimiento
vamos a entrar
la ecuación no
para ver qué sentido tiene todo esto
se es igual hace sé que quiere decir la
primera se es conciencia tenemos que
tomar conciencia de lo que ocurre pero
cómo tomamos conciencia de lo que pasa
pasamos a la siguiente y es observación
observar todo lo que ocurre observar
cada experiencia pero eso no es
suficiente tenemos que entrar en la
pregunta pregunta a tu ego desestabiliza
a tu personalidad
pero eso no es suficiente tenemos que
ir más allá entrar en un análisis
profundo de la realidad tenemos que
además abrirnos a la posibilidad de
aprender de la experiencia
entonces
el análisis es sobre la pregunta porque
no es entrar en una pregunta del por qué
por qué me pasa esto por qué por qué por
qué para qué
hacernos muchas preguntas
pero eso tampoco es suficiente porque lo
que necesitamos ahora es entrar en una
etapa de exponencial y that y ahí viene
[Música]
la práctica la práctica constante de
todo lo que aprendes porque la
información sin práctica es inexistente
todo lo que ven anterior a la práctica
es información yo analizo la información
que me llega por los sentidos que
observo que me lleva a la pregunta
pero
todo esto me lleva a donde esto me lleva
a la comprensión
entonces la fórmula se iguala se quiere
decir conciencia es igual a comprensión
no podemos ser conscientes de algo si no
logramos comprender lo que ocurre
me gustaría que ahora
hagamos una mínima dinámica una pequeña
dinámica si les parece bien y
verificamos un poco en primera persona
lo que hemos hablado nos levantamos por
favor
bien
lo que vamos a hacer ahora es cerrar los
ojos
y vamos a conectar
con un evento traumático
de vuestra vida con un evento que te
haya incomodado con un evento que te
haya llevado a la tristeza a la
frustración
observa la emoción siente la emoción que
hay en ese evento traumático visualiza
eso tenlo y ahora voy a contar de 5 a 1
cuando llegue a 1
vamos a esa emoción ese evento
traumático que hemos visualizado y vamos
a decir gracias porque necesitamos
entrar en una toma de conciencia
profunda de 'top de que todo lo que
ocurre es perfecto y necesario y 543 2
gracias
abrimos los ojos podemos sentarnos un
momentito
para terminar les quiero decir que no
crean absolutamente nada de lo que les
he contado
porque mi propuesta no es sumar
creencias
mi propuesta es que verifiquen toda la
información en primera persona porque la
verdad lo que yo les he contado es mi
verdad y la verdad no puede ser
transferible la verdad tiene que ser
experimentada
para terminar
una pregunta cómo nos la pasó haciendo
preguntas
cuántos de ustedes estarán dispuestos
a morir hoy teniendo la certeza de que
pueden renacer en una nueva versión de
sí mismos
muchísimas gracias por su atención y
gracias por existir